ancré à gauche depuis 17 années
consécutives le canton de saint cyr
l'école comprend actuellement six
communes bois-d'arcy chavenay fontenay
fleury rennes moulin villepreux
essentiel écoles ancien député et
conseiller général sortant socialiste
jean philippe mallet se présente cette
année avec son binôme fabienne jargon
bilbo conseillère municipale de
villepreux il se bat notamment pour un
pluralisme politique dans le département
qui l'estiment nécessaire
vous savez le président conseil général
des yvelines pierre bédier partout peu
la drogue peut faire le grand chelem
donc je pose la question aux yvelinois
est-ce qu'il est sain pour une
collectivité pour la bonne marche d'une
collectivité pour la démocratie locale
qu'il y ait une assemblée départementale
l'assemblée d'une collectivité
territoriale monocolore d'une seule
couleur politique uniquement gérer
quand parker je ne pense pas parmi les
principaux dossiers dans lequel il
souhaite continuer à s'impliquer la
création de logements dans le cadre de
la loi du grand paris mais aussi le
dossier de la tangentielle ouest ces
transports en commun qui devrait relier
la gare de saint cyr l'école à la gare
de saint-germain-en-laye avant d'être
relié à achères par la suite un projet
porté notamment par l'état la région ile
de france et le département des yvelines
philippe benassaya actuel maire ump de
bois d'arcy a su faire basculer sa vie
la droite aux élections municipales
l'année dernière avec son binôme sonia
bros première adjointe au maire de saint
cyr l'école
il compte bien ne pas s'arrêter là et
transformer l'essai sur le canton de
saint cyr pour la première fois j'ai le
soutien et nous avons le soutien action
ya bros de tous les maires du canton et
ça c'est une situation exceptionnelle
on n'a jamais connu le feu à droite ou à
gauche quand le quand on était à droite
ou à gauche on n'a jamais connu cela sur
ce canton
soutenu par tous les maires du canton
philippe benassaya n'hésite pas
également à mettre en avant son
expérience du terrain
plusieurs axes de campagne sont cités
c'est la voirie c'est la circulation les
transports et surtout pour nous à
bonnart si la réussite éducative le
numérique
ça c'est important et bien sûr tout ce
qui touche les familles l'aide aux
handicapés les seniors et tout cela et
ça ce sont des pistes très importante
pour notre canton
dans ce canton trois autres listes se
présentent dalila bouderait et jean-yves
maximilien au nom du front de gauche
europe ecologie les verts julien grimm
et perrine géniaux pour le fn et sylvia
cantaluppi avec christophe pitel pour
debout la france en 2008 jean philippe
mallet l'avait remporté au second tour
face à jean françois lasserre le maire
de fontenay fleuri avec 58,7 % des
suffrages